So, don't be deterred
by a no in any way.
Frankly, I got so many no's in 2017.
But, and obviously there were
self-doubt moments as well.
I was like, oh my God,
am I doing this the right way?
I don't know what's going on.
Spandana Palaypu,
thank you so much for joining me
all the way from
the United Arab Emirates.
How are you?
Good. Good. Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you very much for being here.
I just came back
from a wonderful trip to Dubai.
It was remarkable,
eye-opening and getting to know
a whole new, very similar,
yet very different culture.
I'm calling from Tel Aviv.
And I think that although
the locals in Dubai and Israelis
are very similar in a lot of ways,
there's a lot of cultural differences
in how business is done,
how relationships are formed.
So, I think it was very fascinating.
I'm glad to hear that.
I mean, considering
everything's opened up now,
I'm just glad to see that,
you know, things are progressing
in the right direction.
100%. And while
we're waiting for you here in Tel Aviv,
but in the meantime,
I'll have to gauge your brain here
in these next 20 minutes.
Spandana, you've had a remarkable
journey leading up to ZoEasy.
And I'd love to focus on that as well.
But first, I have to go back
and understand a little bit
about your passions
and the different things
that you've done
from the different speaking engagements
and being ambassadors
of different organizations.
I actually also participated
in the EPGY program at Stanford,
just like you did.
But tell me a little bit about
what's been happening
with you up until now.
So, honestly, like just a regular
25 year old if you ask me.
The whole drive around
education and employment,
that was always
instilled in me as a child.
To be honest, I've always been
the kind of person
that was into community service
and doing things
in relation to education.
I used to teach in high school
and I used to teach kids
from underprivileged backgrounds
and I used to teach children
with learning disabilities as well.
So, education and employment
have always been very close to my heart.
And I also come from a very strong
entrepreneurial family.
So, like my dad's an entrepreneur,
my uncle's an entrepreneur.
So, you know, that I think also
kind of instilled a little bit
of that business part within me
when I was younger.
And I knew that I wanted to do something
that was in relation to education,
employment or health care.
But I didn't really know
what was the right path
to kind of pursue for that.
Do I go into medicine,
because medicine was something
that I had considered at one point.
Or do I go into business.
And being from a traditional
South Indian family,
you know, business is usually like
a wary subjected to you.
Either go into engineering
or you go into medicine.
Those are your two key career choices.
But I remember sitting my parents down
and like taking them
through this entire decision matrix
of who I thought like business
was the right options.
And post university, honestly,
it reached a point where
I wanted to actually go into consulting
before starting my own social enterprise,
because ultimately that was the end goal.
But as I was applying for jobs
and I even got an offer
from a big four.
At the same time,
I was also working on ZoEasy as an idea
because, I mean, growing up in the UAE
you do get to interact with people
from diverse backgrounds,
different walks of life.
And a big part of that
is the blue collar community.
And so, hearing their stories is truly
it's a remarkable experience
because you meet engineers
who are working as cleaners.
You'll meet waiters who actually
have teaching backgrounds.
So, you know, these are people
that are actually skilled
but end up in different circumstances,
mainly because of middlemen
and brokers in their home countries
who sell them a dream,
which is very different to reality.
And in the process,
they even pay almost $3,000
to find employment abroad, you know.
So, that was when
that spark kind of instilled within me,
and I knew that this was like,
this was my purpose and my passion.
And so, when somebody had come forward
and shown an interest
in investing in ZoEasy
and so that was when I decided, okay,
let's give this path a try
and see how that goes.
Let's talk a little bit more about this,
about, you know, the circumstances
when you see blue color,
what do you mean by that?
So, anybody that,
so, in the UAE, a blue collar worker
is essentially defined
as somebody that earns about
5,000 dirhams or less.
And you have a variation
of these professions.
So, it ranges from unskilled
to skilled to semi-skilled.
And what I mean by unskilled is
so, for example, if you ask somebody
to pick up a box
and put it somewhere like,
something like that,
that would be considered
an unskilled person.
But you can also go up
to a skill level where,
you know, sometimes some nurses
and some nurses
are also considered as a part
of the blue/gray collar industry.
So, it's a very wide variation.
So, it ranges from waiters
to the construction industry,
hospitality facilities management,
a lot of people that work
in these industries fall into
the blue collar community.
And there are almost
four million blue collar workers
in the UAE.
So, that's 43% of the population.
It's a massive, yes,
it's a massive number.
It's a huge part of the community.
So, you get to interact
with them on a regular basis.
And that's how I grew up.
You know, like I was always exposed
to different nationalities,
different communities,
different backgrounds.
And so, that's where you hear
about these stories.
So, tell me a little bit about ZoEasy.
What were some of the insights
that you've gained
on how to potentially tackle
these circumstances
that obviously are not ideal?
Of course.
So, like I mentioned of
as I was doing my research
and speaking to more people, you know,
I realized that it's not actually
a problem that starts in the UAE.
It's a problem that starts
at the very source,
from the country that
these job seekers are coming from.
They're coming to the UAE
to find better employment opportunities.
And honestly, I have come across
many people who, yes,
have come here under a certain pretext.
But after joining the firm
and understanding that
there are ethical employers out here,
they have been able to save up
and create a better standard of living
for their families back home
at the end of it.
But what we aim to do
and what we want to bring as a change
to the whole system
is essentially removing
this network of middlemen.
Because both employers and job seekers
have to go through
about six layers of middlemen
before an employee is actually hired.
So, employers aren't exactly benefiting
because there is no other alternatives
in the market, you know.
You have a lot
of white-collar talent platforms
out there,
but you don't have anything
that is catering
to the blue collar community.
And so, in the process,
you have to rely
on this paper based archaic system.
And a lot of employers do pay for,
they pay these middlemen
recruitment fees,
but they end up with job seekers
that aren't exactly the right fit
for what they're looking for.
Similarly, job seekers
don't exactly have the right guidance
or skills to be able
to find employment opportunities
that are in line
with their career aspirations.
And so, in the process,
this is the only method that's out there.
This has been happening
for the last 40 to 50 years.
There's no other alternatives
in the industry.
And so you rely on a middleman
who sells you this wonderful dream.
Oh, you're going to be right next
to the Burj Khalifa.
It's going to be a great, great job,
great experience for you.
And that message
that the employer puts forward
gets completely diluted
by the time it reaches the job seeker.
So, in the process,
employers aren't happy,
jobseekers aren't happy.
Both have shed money
because it goes to the middlemen.
So, it's not a win win
for either party, to be honest.
And that's what we're trying to tackle.
Ensure that good employers
get access to good people
and good people get access
to the right employment opportunities
so that they can create
a better standard of living
for their families back home.
And you mentioned that a part of it,
part of the dissonance
that we have here is that,
people that have certain skill sets,
they don't actually come to fruition
in locally in the UAE,
where you're specifically looking at.
How is ZoEasy actually
compromising on that?
Right.
So, we actually,
so one, we did a pilot
placement, actually.
We wanted to understand
how the system worked
and what the issues were around
this whole sector.
And you don't really have
a lot of data out there
in relation to this industry
unless you go and you tackle
this first hand yourself.
So, we did a pilot placement
of 150 people.
We also generated a massive database,
but from within that database,
we chose one 150 people,
150 job seekers that we could place
within different industries.
So, we looked at industries
like construction, hospitality
and so on.
And we understood
what the hindrances were offline
and what were the processes
that we could move online
to make the system more ethical
and more transparent.
And that could also help jobseekers
showcase their skills in better ways.
So, that's where we came up
with the concept of implementing things
like video CVs and live interviewing.
Because many of these job seekers
don't know how to write good CVs,
but they know
how to express themselves really well.
So, that's where these tools
will come in to provide
a more holistic perspective
of the job seeker.
And that also reduces a lot of
like the travel costs that are involved
for employers who would otherwise
have to travel to India
or travel to parts of Southeast Asia
in order to be able to recruit people
from the ground.
You know what I mean?
Right.
So, just for context,
out of the 40% blue collar workers
in the UAE,
what is the estimated percentage of them
that could be transformed
into skilled workers
but they're just out of circumstance,
positioned as blue collar workers
in unskilled positions?
Honestly, a big chunk.
I would say easily about
28 to 30% can be converted.
It's a big chunk.
There are people, there are first timers
that come out here
and then move up the ladder.
There are people like that.
But a big majority that you meet
are actually skilled people
who have ended up
in the wrong employment opportunities
because of some middlemen
in their home country.
So, it's about the way
you showcase your skills
and how you can put that forward.
And what we do is we explicitly
work with ethical employers.
So, we look for employers
who have strong HR, CSR policies in place.
We work with employers
who have a focus on diversity
and inclusion because,
you know, industries like manufacturing,
for example, they don't employ
a lot of women,
even though a lot of women
can actually be skilled for that job.
And in fact, we tied up
with one such employer recently,
like Deltron Paints is very focused
on diversity and inclusion,
and they want to include more women
in the workforce.
So, finding employers like that
to work with is also very important
because they create
a great environment
for the candidate to thrive in.
And so, we identify employers
like that to work with.
But simultaneously,
you also need to look
at the job seeker themselves.
And it's not just about
the skill that they have,
but their personality
also plays a big role
in who they are.
I mean, we placed somebody
that was actually
from the logistics industry.
And he was earning about
1500 dirhams a month. Right?
Wow.
And yeah, he was earning
1500 dirhams a month to start with.
And something happened at his workplace.
One of his coworkers
had said, it was,
there was a racial comment made
towards him.
So, he decided to leave.
And he had a 30 day grace period
within which he had to find
another employment opportunity.
And so, that's when
we got connected.
And when we met him, honestly, he is
one of the most wonderful people
you will meet.
He's so great to talk to
and he has so much wisdom to give.
I mean, there were things that
I learned as a person from him.
Some of his quotes were unbelievable.
And that's when
I realized that this guy
could actually be a great fit
in the hospitality industry
and he'd be able to earn
even more than
what he was earning
in the logistics space.
And so, we placed him
with the hospitality employer.
And he I mean, there was
he almost had like
a 50% boost in his salary
because you're not only getting a base,
but you're also getting tips
from customers
and you know how to interact with people.
That's your strength
so, why not use it.
Well, I think that's just remarkable.
So, if you look at the vision
a few years forward,
what's going to happen with ZoEasy
as far as you're seeing it?
Honestly, for me,
like five years down the line,
I want to make sure that
we help educate
and find ethical employment opportunities
for one million job seekers, at least.
And honestly, the aim is to become
the go to platform
for the migrant workforce.
We want to be that platform
that the migrant workforce can turn to,
especially in relation
to these specific fields.
And essentially,
what that contributes towards
more than anything
is helping people find
like attain economic empowerment.
Right?
When you attain economic empowerment,
you're reducing inequalities
in the community.
You're creating greater diversity
in the community,
and you're also having a ripple effect.
So, it's not just that one person
that you're impacting,
but you are actually impacting
five other people in their families
and creating a better
standard of living for them
and a better standard of living
for generations to come.
So, it's not just that one person
you're impacting, but it has
a ripple effect
across multiple generations.
I think that's wonderful.
And I want to spend more
time talking about ZoEasy,
but I also really want to gauge
your brain on the different
activities that you've done.
For example, the World Economic Forum
and the work that you're doing there.
Tell me,
how did you get involved with that
and what is the work that you're doing?
Honestly, it all comes down
to networking.
So, I've come to realize
that's a good trait to have.
If you know how to reach out
to the right people
and just basically
know how to get people engaged with you
and invest in you as a person
and also invest in your ideas.
Right?
So, I actually came across
the Global Shapers community
at One Young World,
which is another youth,
large youth network and organization.
So, I was a delegate speaker
at One Young World 2018 in The Hague.
And somebody
from the Global Shapers community
had seen me speak.
And so, we connected afterwards
and she told me
about this wonderful community.
And what I really like
about the Global Shapers community,
honestly, is the fact that
you have people,
you have young leaders,
but who come from
so many different backgrounds
and who have
so many different skill sets.
But you're all working towards
the same vision.
You all want to create
some form of social impact
in the community.
And the WEFs key pillars are focused
on education and employment,
equity and inclusion
and the environment.
So, these are the three main areas
that they look at, and these are all
three passion areas for me.
So, I joined the Global Shapers community
in early 2019, and I was actually
a part of helping one of their,
now biggest projects.
So, Global Shapers Dubai's
current biggest project
is with a foundation called
the Al Ghurair's Foundation for Education,
and they provide scholarships
to underprivileged youth
for universities.
And the person that was leading
this initiative at the beginning,
I had helped him assist
with putting out the first workshop
and taking them
through project management courses,
how to raise funding,
how to basically put your idea out there
and make sure that it grows.
Because practically, experience,
at the end of the day
is very different to
what you learn at university
or in a classroom. Right?
So, that was one
of the first education initiatives
that we've launched.
Now I'm the vice curator of the hub,
so, I'm also part of the leadership team
and helping manage it,
but also ensuring that more projects
are coming out in relation
to the other pillars as well.
And we actually did
a really cool initiative recently,
like we launched
something called the elevate series.
So, me and a fellow global shaper,
we're co-leading that together.
And we did a pilot
with an NGO in India.
And the idea was to basically provide
skills training around
building better resumes, presentations,
social media skills using CANVA.
And it was so interesting to see
over the span of two days,
we were able to reach 160 girls
in 23 countries.
And we never expected that.
So, I'm glad to see
that it is an initiative
that has the potential to grow
and create more sustainable impact.
And that's what I love about
the community as well.
Fantastic.
What are some nuggets of wisdom
that you can provide
for young entrepreneurs
that are just young people in general
that are looking to affect
so called change, that are looking
to make an impact either
in their local community
or broader than that?
You know,
we humbly forgot to mention
that you were chosen
for Forbes 30 under 30
for the amazing work
that you're doing.
But I'd love to hear a little bit
about your insights as to
how other young people
can get involved
with similar initiatives.
Honestly, I feel like
if you are passionate about something
and you believe in your idea,
then first things first
is actually lay out a budget.
That's the first thing to do.
Put a budget down,
see if this is something
that can be viable.
Especially because, you know,
you do want to create impact
in the world,
but you also need to know
how to survive.
Without being able to survive,
you won't be able to affect that change
at a larger scale.
So, yes, start at the grassroots level,
but first things first,
lay down a budget.
See if this is a viable project,
see if there is a way to put it out,
and then create a good story around it.
Because, yes, you can talk numbers
and numbers are very important,
but in order to get people
to invest in you
and believe in your idea,
you also need to know
how to communicate your vision properly
to others.
So, I think it's very important
to kind of combine
those two skills together.
So, balancing storytelling
with the numbers that you have
in place that show that
this is a big problem out there
and there is a viable solution
which you want to provide.
And finally, I would say one in
first things first invest in yourself,
learn as much as possible.
I went in completely blind.
I was a first line entrepreneur.
I had no idea
how to do any of this stuff,
but I had a great set of mentors.
And honestly, because of them,
I've been able to come this far.
So, network, find yourself good mentors
who can guide you in the right direction
and do a lot of research
and start reaching out
to the right networks as well.
Because especially if you're
a young entrepreneur,
you want to meet people
that are also young entrepreneurs
that have gone along
a similar journey
and who understand the process
and who can guide you.
So, do your research,
get access to networks
like One Young World.
One Young World is a brilliant platform
for you to connect with young innovators
who are facilitating change
around the world.
So, reach out to networks
like One Young World,
reach out to networks
like the Global Shapers community.
Try to identify more networks
that you can be a part of
where you can connect with people.
Randomly cold call.
What's the worst that can happen?
I mean, somebody will say no, that's it.
It's okay if someone says no,
no problem.
Just move on to the next thing.
But keep them posted on what's happening,
obviously, because, one,
when you're company starts to grow,
it will be likely
that they will come back
and reach out themselves.
So, it may be a closed door now,
but it'll open up at a later stage.
So, don't be deterred
by a no in any way.
Frankly, I got so many no's in 2017,
but, and obviously there were
self-doubt moments as well.
I was like, oh my God,
am I doing this the right way?
I don't know what's going on.
But you know one yes
can really change the entire game.
I love that.
Spandana, thank you so much for being
so kind with your time.
This was really wonderful.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you the most difficult
and most important question,
which is three words
that we'd use to describe yourself.
That's a very interesting one.
It is a tough one.
That's like the most difficult one,
I would say.
Right.
I'm a people person.
So, very friendly, empathetic.
I am also very diverse as a person.
I know diverse
is not exactly like a proper adjective,
but I would say diversity is
a big part of me based on
so many different factors.
So, diversity.
And curious. I would say I'm curious.
Yeah, curious.
Thank you so much
for joining me here,
this was wonderful.
I can't wait to share this
with the world.
And I can't wait
to have more interaction
both between the nations,
but also maintaining this connection
and keeping open doors
and then potentially
working together sometimes.
So, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
Take care.
Bye.